cinquante ans assurant des femmes du
monde assure qu est ce que je veux dire
c'est c'est le rap qui contrôle
aujourd'hui sera pas première musique et
il faut faire avec l'arrêt des niño qui
vendent plus que puisque n'importe qui à
dennis k qui vendent plus que n'importe
qui est des mecs qui vont de choses que
je veux dire tu vois quand tu écoutes je
sais pas tu écoutes serge gainsbourg
t'écoute la javanaise gérer ses biens et
des chansons françaises ou ses écrits de
devenir compliqué que c'est pas vraiment
pas du bon français le gentil souriant
une chanson qui s'appelle camp est clair
après qu'une chanson de moi dans mon
humble taciturne ou jeudi
si j'aurais grandit d'ailleurs je me
demande ce que j'aurais été jeudi si
j'aurais parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
parle dans mon quartier c'est ce que je
veux dire et je suis conscient de ce que
je fonction de ce que j'écris à ce
moment là donc comme tryo est en fait qu
on fait des fautes d'orthographe alors
on s'en bat les couilles de skicross
parce que d'éducation accessible à tout
le monde c'est juste que c'est un fait
il ya parfois des gens crient pas mal
mais c'est pas uniquement dans les
quartiers parce que le vert
je pense qu'il ya des pnc des poètes
avec faith un poète dame sosa un poids
être ni néo ses impôts être parce que je
veux je peux discuter des phrases sais
où je me disais c'est des cons stade la
trique que j'écoute beaucoup en ce
moment c'est tout un goût de chez de
dinho il commence en disant il y aura
plus jamais d'anonymat même si je même
si je retire le tablier ça qui en fait
le con style traumatisant fait c'est la
manière de commencer sa chanson exiger
une famille trop grande à nourrir man je
peux pas mourir pour mon malgré son
sacre royal
c'est le constat ya même pas de jeu de
mots c'est juste la manière de 2,2 de
t'expliquer ce qu'il ressent je pense
que l'arabe est officiellement partie du
français marché a fait tout ce que je
veux dire ses bras ouais ouais sauf que
wes jeudi de nenê que shakespeare c'est
ya tellement de mots français qui
viennent de l'arabe
je pense qu'il faut s'adapter à ça et à
accepter que dire au calme c'est et
grands-parents du rcam dans en 43 est
comme quand on était petit avait déjà
des mots strauss son entrée dans le
dictionnaire
moi je suis tout petit ma mère âgée de
50 ans est dit mon gars sur des fois
mais bien sûr tout ce que je veux dire
dont c'est ça montre à quel point tu
sais le truc il est un peu déjà ouais ça
peut dire qu'un détruites après sagesse
que j'adore classés
c'est l'enseignement que je parle depuis
depuis toujours donc c'est explicable
c'est ma langue c'est la langue que j'ai
apprise à l'école j'ai pas ta français
qui tu parles à la maison tu as français
différents cantons quartier par français
différents comptes quant à l'école
apprend c'est différent quand tu rappes
et je pense que je pense que c'est ce
qui fait le charme de la langstrasse
chaque villa à son arc d'autres c'est la
langue tellement riche et ses deux
langues qui évoluent tellement avec avec
le temps et avec la jeunesse
je pense qu'elle est morte
toutes les choses que l'on a pu lire les
classer par l albatros schopenhauer du
freud je sais pas si j'ai le cdh est
important c'est important d'élire en ce
moment je n'ai un livre s'appelle
d'énergie du silence quand même très
bien de sa part de ce focus sur soi même
et fermé 5 1 il faut faire le sac et
bien sûr
[Musique]